this is crazy but you guys got crazy cat
people for a reason i feel like i
probably was a cat
in another life
hi my name is jasper sams and this
is taxi my name is alex and this here is
squeaks say hi squeaks
[Music]
hi guys i'm emma and i'm actually here
with bowie
that's figgy he's the patriarch of the
family
my boyfriend adam his cousin was like
this cat has changed cats for me so
we're very proud of that
hi my name is alex and this is my cat
rebel
he's known in my family as the forever
kitten because
he has not grown up a day since we first
got him i am ready for this cat trivia
i'm so excited but i say i know a lot
about cats
i think i know a fair amount bring it on
i'm gonna do it i'm gonna
crush it i do enjoy trivia i do enjoy
games
and i do enjoy winning
cats will select food based on flavor or
aroma
i don't know what else they would base
their food on yeah i might say go ahead
that's true
i'm gonna go with true for that that
just sounds true sounds like you know
what people do
true oh
okay cats are into nutrition i did not
know that
a direct stare from a cat is a sign of
trust and affection
yeah i want to say true i mean it makes
sense both ways
i'm gonna go with false i'm gonna go
with churro i think that's
false
[Music]
cats make about a hundred different
sounds to communicate
i know i know
true i'm going to go with false i want
to say true his meow when he gets
kind of like really hungry we'll be like
no
ears can't tell the difference but i'm
going to say that's false
[Music]
yay the average house cat can jump up to
five feet without a running start i feel
like i've seen him do it yes
so i'm gonna say it's true i feel like
it's more than that
so yeah i guess i'll go with false
cats try to manipulate humans with their
meows true or
false that one is true and i will die on
that hill
true he follows you around and you also
try to get you to feed him or get your
attention so i'm gonna go ahead and say
that's true
i feel like that is what they're doing
when they meow so i say true
you can stimulate an indoor cat's
hunting abilities with interactive toys
i think that that is true because cats
go into like a different mode when
they're playing with
interactive toys well i use the laser
pointer all the time so i'm going to say
that
is true i know that whenever we play
with taxi's rainbow snake
he just goes crazy true
yay cats have almost 20 muscles that
control their ears
true i want to say they have more so i'm
going to say that's
false i'm going to go with true false
cats will lick or groom themselves after
you pet them to get rid of your scent
that's true i don't know bless you
i'm just gonna say true you know that
sounds true but i feel like my cat
doesn't do that
the answer is true
ah taste my scent guys you're really
enlightening me here this is cool
i've heard that if cats were big enough
they would eat us
so that checks out i'm glad that they're
small after playing with their human
companions for 10 minutes
cats saw a 12 increase of oxytocin
or the love hormone true false
i just think it's true i mean if we're
being quite honest i didn't even know
cats really had
a love hormone i just thought that they
had love in their hearts
this one is true yes
[Music]
that's amazing did you hear that we won
it's like whatever
congrats to whoever did win ah
i'm still sorry squeaks yeah to be
honest this is
um probably gonna ruin my day so thanks
guys
foreign